jetzt noch mal genau dieser frau warum
bosco mit aber das habe ich ihnen doch
schon gesagt weil ich ein blind date
habe mit einem mann war man ja arme mann
wallis blind glücklicher machen weil er
muss nicht an große frau wenn es nicht
so aufgeregt werden muss doch nicht
aufgeregt seien blind date aziz wie
taufen katze im sack was soll das heißen
dass heißt gar nichts das ist nur
schmuck aus wenn wir einmal baff wie ich
bin das leben ist fährt folgende szene
gegenstands ist auch nichts den künstler
aufgeregt was wenn er mich blöd findet
oder wenn ich ihn blöd finde
doppelt hält besser apropos idiot ist
eine blind date bringt ja hoffen ich
erkenne ich ihn auch sofort ja warum du
nichts ausgemacht hat der kennung
zeichen wie zum beispiel blume auf jacke
oder große waldsee auf nase und der
regierung clinton
ich hab doch nicht den glatten verlauf
gedanken natürlich haben wir ein kleines
zeichen ausgemacht er hat einen
schnauzbart und trägt eine lederhose wie
man den ball
ich muss mir jetzt rein ja ich will es
jetzt wissen schnauzbart und lederhose
schnauzbart und lederhose mein prinz ich
komme
[Musik]
[Applaus]